Let's start this video by
throwing a mouse, a dog,
and an elephant from a
skyscraper onto something soft.
Let's say a stack of mattresses,
the mouse lands,
and it's done for a moment before it
shakes itself off and walked away.
Pretty annoyed because that's
a very rude thing to do.
The dog breaks sort of its bones
and dies in an unspectacular away,
and the elephant explodes into a red
bubble of bones and insights and has no
chance to be annoyed.
Why does the mouse survive?
But the elephant and dog don't?
The answer is size.
Size is the most underappreciated
regulator of living things.
Size determines everything about
our biology, how we are built,
how we experience the world,
how we live and die.
It does so because the physical laws are
different for different sized animals.
Life spans seven orders of magnitude from
invisible bacteria to Mites and mice,
dogs, humans, elephants and blue whales.
Every size lives in its own unique
universal right next to each other,
each with its own rules,
upsides and downsides.
We'll explore these different
worlds in a series of videos.
Let's get back to the initial question.
Why did our mouse, it survived the fall
because of how scaling
size changes everything.
The principle that we'll meet over and
over again, very small things for example,
are practically immune to fording from
great heights because the smaller you are,
the less you care about
the effect of gravity.
Imagine a theoretical spherical
animal the size of a marble.
It has three features.
It's length,
it's surface area which is covered in
skin and it's volume or or the stuff
inside it like organs,
muscles, hopes and dreams.
If we make it 10 times longer,
say the size of a basketball,
the rest of it's features
don't just grow 10 times,
its skin will grow 100 times and it's
insights or its volume grows by 1000
times.
The volume determines the weight or
more accurately mass of the animal.
The more mass you have,
the higher your kinetic energy before
you hit the ground and the stronger the
impact shock, the more surface area in
relation to your volume or mass you have,
the more the impact gets distributors
and softened and also the more air
resistance will slow you down.
And elephant is so big that
it has extremely little
surface area in ratio to its
volume, so a lot of kinetic energy gets
distributed over a small space and the ad
doesn't slow it down much at all.
That's why it's completely destroyed in
an impressive explosion of Goo when it
hits the ground.
The other extreme in insects have a huge
surface area in relation to their tiny
mask,
so you can literally throw an ad from an
Arab pain and it will not be seriously
harmed, but while falling is
irrelevant in the small world,
there are other forces
that are harmless for us,
but extremely dangerous for
small banks like surface tension,
which turns water into eight potentially
deadly substance for insects.
How does it work?
Water has the tendency to stick to itself.
It's molecules are attracted to each
other through a force called cohesion,
which creates a tension on its surface
that you can imagine it as a sort of
invisible skin. For us, this skin is
so weak that we don't even notice it.
Normally if you get wet about 800 grams
of water or about 1% of your body weight
sticks to you, a wet mouth has about
three grams of water sticking to it,
which is more than 10% of its body weight.
Imagine having eight full water bottle
sticking to you when you leave the shower,
but for an insect, the force of
water surface tension is so strong.
The getting wet is a
question of life and death.
If we were to shrink you to the
size of an ant and you touch water,
it will be like you were reaching into
glue. It would quickly and go, phew,
it's surface tension too hard
for you to break and you drown.
So insects evolve to be water repellent.
For one,
their exoskeleton is covered with a
thin layer of wax, just like a car.
This makes their surface at least partly
water repellent because it can't stick
to it very well.
Many insects are also covered with
tiny hairs that serves as a barrier.
They vastly increase their surface area
and prevent the droplets from touching
that exoskeleton and make it easier
to get rid of droplets to make use of
surface tension,
evolution,
cracked and nanotechnology
billions of years before us.
Some insects have evolved a
surface covered by a short
and extremely dense coat
of water repelling hair.
Some have more than a million has passed
square millimeter when the insect dives
under water as stays inside there
for and forms a coat of air,
water content and because there has a
too tiny to break its surface tension,
but it gets even better as the
oxygen of the Arab oil runs out,
new oxygen diffuses into the bubble from
the water around it while the carbon
dioxide diffuses outwards into the
water and so the insect carries its own
outside lung around and can basically
breathe underwater thanks to surface
tension. This is the same principle that
enables pawn skaters to walk on water.
By the way,
tiny anti water has the smaller you get
the where do the environment becomes at
some point even app becomes
more and more solid.
Let's now zoom down to the
smallest insects known about
half the size of a grain
of salt, only 0.15 millimeters
long. The ferry fly,
they live in a world even weirder
than other insects. For them,
air itself is length, thin Jello, a syrup
like mass surrounding them at all times.
Movement through it is not
easy flying on this level.
It's not like attic and gliding.
They have to kind of grab and hold onto
it so their wings look like big hairy
arms rather than proper insect wings.
They literally swim through the APP
like a tiny gross alien through Sarah,
things only become stranger from here on.
As we explore more,
universities have different sizes.
The physical rules are so
different for each size.
That evolution had to engineer around
them over and over as life grew in size in
the last billion years. So why are
there no ants? The science of horses?
Why no elephants the size of Amoeba?
Why?
We'll discuss this in the next part.
We have a monthly newsletter.
Now sign up if you don't want to miss
new videos and foot bonus videos.